and so imagine especially if it's a new
hobby you know so can I challenge that
oh come on because now I have a new
hobby I'm proud of my work I want to
snap a photo and put it on social media
so you can make money from that now it's
always some competition that is true
that is true that that is actually true
and you know what you get a high five
okay
because I'm going to be honest that is
true it can totally lead you back into
the cycle but now think about this what
is Tick Tock doing to your brain find
out on this episode of LED live
foreign
[Music]
welcome to LED live it's the show where
we use the Light of Christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today we have Mia on the show with us
thank you so much for being here she is
a mental health coach and she's here to
talk with us about tick tock's effect on
our brains which is a very interesting
topic and if you guys have Tick Tock I
do you do I I don't but I've heard it's
like Instagram on steroids it's like
ridiculous yeah I've promised myself to
never make one so I haven't oh wow okay
but before we get into the topic I have
to shout out our patrons thank you so
much you're literally the ones who make
this show possible that we are able to
continue posting videos every single
Friday at noon so thank you so much if
you want to join our Patron family check
out patreon.com Little Light Studios or
you can donate directly through our
website littlelightstudios.tv
man none of us are wearing lightwear
shirts that's unfortunate but you can
get your own lightwear t-shirt or
stickers at lightwear dot shop all that
information is in the description box
below all right without further Ado
let's talk about Tick Tock yeah wow I'm
so glad that we were talking about this
you know as a mental health coaching
consultant sometimes it really hurts me
when I see that people are not aware you
know and it's really big to be aware
because once you are aware of something
you can actually decide and when you can
decide something you can attract you can
attract the right things the things that
you want and so a lot of people are
interested in attracting right and so
who wouldn't want to attract health and
wellness and beauty and so what do we do
we get on Tick Tock right we get on
there and we're like you know what I
need a fabulous body let me look and see
who has one scrolling scrolling
scrolling and what happens in the end
right after scrolling and looking
do you remember feeling kind of down low
like it's impossible
well it's all a part of the system you
know and it's interesting because I as a
content creator I was thinking let's get
on Tick Tock Mia you know how am I going
to be able to get out there and reach a
lot of people and some people think
that's the case but actually people have
very few followers even though it seems
like oh there's so many people uh
following me and I just want to say the
way that Tick Tock is made it is
literally made to grab you and keep you
so have you ever been stuck in a
conversation right you've got to go
somewhere you really need to get some
stuff done and you can't seem to get out
of it you're like okay how can I like
you know tap out well tick tock's
literally like that like it's really
hard to tap out and it's actually made
on purpose like I was looking at some
articles that were produced by Mayo
Clinic and it was literally saying from
the moment you come on the screen for
tick tock you are instantly rewarded so
there's that there's parts of your brain
that receive reward right like your
nucleus accumbens and when you get on
there you're being rewarded by bam a
image right then and there those videos
or whatever and so it just kind of sucks
you in and grabs you in and keeps you
there and what I didn't know which I'm
so glad to be able to share with you is
that not only is it grabbing you in but
even the constant motion of you sliding
and scrolling right you can um I heard
one of the people in their article say
it's synonymous with a person that is
going to gamble and they're now at the
slot machine do you remember slot
machines maybe you were know about them
maybe you don't so like imagine you know
a slot machine right you know you got
the pictures and it's scrolling you're
scrolling scrolling scrolling and it's
actually giving you a reward one to
scroll but then two when you hit a good
video this is like ah I got a good one
and actually the bad videos are embedded
in there so that you get that sense of
suspense like what's going to happen
next is it going to be a good video or
is it going to be a bad video what's
going to happen you know and all of this
is giving your brain that dopamine rush
or it's giving you that sense of like oh
wow I have to keep going I have to stay
in this and and you know what I noticed
and I'm sorry to cut you off no go ahead
I think it's what's fascinating is that
when I jump in it whether it be reels
whether it be Tick Tock or whether it be
uh whatever the other one the term is
they use shorts I think it's a YouTube's
version right
um they give you the best one at the
beginning and you're like wow and so now
you're hooked you're gonna find the next
one and I've noticed as you go along all
of a sudden there's a video is like I
was expecting something to explode I was
expecting some baby to uh bomb and then
be caught or something right what
happened oh and then I look at the
comments and it's like zero comments
zero proof they've snuck that one in
there as that suspense exactly exactly
and that is what makes it so malicious
actually
because this is calculated to do that
for you you know so that you will have
that response that okay what's going to
happen next kind of like watching a
movie you know that that built-in sense
of okay what's going to happen next I
have to keep watching so I can see you
know what's going to happen and so
you've got I like to think of it as like
oh the good cash and bad cash like the
good video is oh I've gotten the money
and the bad videos oh no I lost it but
it's just enough you're like well I
won't do that again I'll I'll be able to
beat the system as it were and so what's
also happening when you do that is that
sense of repetition right it's uh
creating a habit exactly this is all
subconscious or is this because for me
when I'm scrolling I mean I guess I
could say Instagram because I don't have
right Tech talk but I know that Tech
talk integrates into Instagram but
I just scroll you know so is this all
subconscious that my brain is just
capturing all these little Notions and
absolutely absolutely it's definitely
subconscious you know like no one's
gonna sit there and be like Oh I'm
suspended so let me keep going you know
it's just it's actually built on how
your brain works so that as you continue
to do it you'll continue to get those
little dings pings Rings all of that so
just like gambling is habit forming Tick
Tock in a sense you're you're gambling
right you're gambling with okay am I
gonna get a good video a bad video
um what constitutes a bad video like a
bad video would be something like that's
not really that interesting right
um it may look just one production like
bad bad video which that would make a
person be like oh that's not that
interesting it's boring
um where it's a good video it's like wow
that was spectacular oh my goodness did
you see that or like was the baby about
to fall oh they caught it all that was a
good video and then a bad video like oh
my this is so boring like what are you
talking about like okay switch does that
make sense yeah I just I thought Tick
Tock had like one of the best algorithms
and the point was to only give you
quote-unquote good videos oh they want
you they want they want they purpose
they purposefully embed bad videos to
give you that every that that that oh
this was good this wasn't good this is
good that wasn't good that's literally
on purpose okay so you know we're
talking about the slot machine and how a
slot machine is so addictive right you
know just even think about a slot
machine the sounds right and you know
this movement that's happening all of
this is that brain Body Connection
that's going on right and it's the same
even with Tick Tock and even we're
talking about Tick Tock but even other
social media platforms you're getting a
ding you're getting a ring you're
getting a like all of these are
contributing to you actually being
connected to this platform and it's
repetition also and you know I don't
know about you all but my mom always
said repetition deepens the impression
you know that's literally true when we
think about brain Pathways you know that
pathway in your brain is constantly
being
um strengthened when you're going
through these different habits and
definitely it's habit forming for you to
continue using platforms like Tick Tock
wow okay so but this is a natural thing
that's happening in our body it's
god-given that these corporations are
trying to take advantage of really I'm
assuming this is more than just one big
social experiment like this is of
benefit to these companies right and the
first thing that comes to mind is
obviously a financial benefit right you
know the longer you stay on their
platform the more hours they can Market
to you know other companies and they can
put their ads on there and so forth and
so on so but like can we get into
because just because something is
natural so to speak if it is
um I guess used in an intemperate way it
can be detrimental so how can that be
detrimental to someone right and so I'm
glad you asked that because you know
when you think about it some of the
people that are suffering from the use
of tick tock the most are actually Youth
and Young adults because as you're
continuing to be inundated with all of
these images you're we're seeing in the
research that many young people are
having body image issues right there's
also this false sense of reality that oh
um because you know in your normal life
you might see someone run down the
street and they're fit right but on Tick
Tock you can get a thousand you know and
so it actually makes you think that
there's so many people that actually
look like this or act like this or do
this it's giving you like that false
sense of reality so we're finding a
greater number of Youth and Young adults
suffering from depression and anxiety
just because of their consumption right
yeah and I've noticed that it even
categorizes this like if you're
interested in Fitness it'll show you a
lot of Fitness right it's not showing me
a lot of Fitness that probably says
something about it I should probably
exercise more but it shows me a lot of
hey how to do things and and
construction I do a lot of Renovations
nice and so and so I'm seeing all this
stuff I'm seeing all the funny stuff too
yeah and so all these categories are
fitting in here and it gives you what
you want exactly and then throws in
something every now and then that's just
kind of off the wall of course you could
respond yeah and you're right the off
the wall is actually calculated and
that's what's so inhumane is that
they're going to calculate things in
there that you don't want and you think
it's random but it's really not it's on
purpose to create that slot machine
thing again right when you get the slot
machine cherry cherry Apple Cherry
Cherry Apple ah Cherry Cherry Cherry yes
let me do it again Cherry Cherry uh you
see what I'm saying so that's that's
what's happening I would to put it kind
of like real world if someone grows up
in a family where all the family is
really athletic yeah it's more likely
that they themselves are going to be
involved in athletics so why is it that
seeing like the example of someone
running or a lot of people running why
would someone go then fall and have a
higher possibility of falling into
depression versus going out for a run
right ooh that's a really good question
and so there are people who in a family
see their family members be athletic and
they become athletic but there's also
people in that same athletic family
who's like why come I'm not like
everybody else right there's that sense
of pressure to become athletic when you
don't have that intrinsically in you to
be it and so that's kind of the issue
does that make sense so like um in the
sense that
imagine we are that child who's now been
embedded into by being in Tick Tock we
have been embedded into that athletic
family but we're the person who is not
that's not our
it's not realistic to think that just
because I see all of these people being
athletic that I can do it today that I
can do it too that I need to do it that
I that this is my destiny just like the
child who's in the family with all these
athletes that has that depression or
anxiety or angst about wow why am I not
like this I'm not like everybody else in
my family I'm Different I am
disconnected from the group and God made
all of us to want connection you know
and so now
um Tick Tock is giving me a um it's
happening in two ways it's giving me a
false sense of connection in the sense
that it's like that family right we're a
family of people who are athletic and
doing these amazing things I should be
able to do this because I'm connected to
this family of people that do this you
know
um
and yet I also as a youth or young adult
may not have the mental maturity to see
all the different Dynamics and aspects
of it you know what I mean so now then
there's the other way to connect is like
okay because God has created this
ultimate connection they're capitalizing
on that I'm giving you a false
connection of making you think that this
is reality and and then on on the same
end I'm now because I'm not able to
achieve it
um being isolated and isolation is a
break in connection a break from what
we've been created to have and to do you
know because I feel like I'm is this is
unattainable but it never really was
this this is
um just like that super athletic family
every athletic family is not athletic
you know like every family is not
athletic there are some people who have
been gifted crafted and they have these
abilities
um and they're exceptional it's like an
exception versus the re the the main the
main goal main reality if that makes
sense but now
um I think because I'm seeing Tick Tock
and there's so many of these images I
believe that the exception is the rule
does that make sense yeah how
important is it for someone to like I
guess for a frontal lobe to be fully
developed when being on social media wow
so is that even important you know
there's a lot of conversation about you
know your frontal lobe and what is
actually maturity you know and we know
that science has already taught us that
very young children really shouldn't be
engaging in media period right and I
know that that's something that a lot of
people don't want to hear because they
just don't have for lack of a better way
to put it what it takes to really
process and digest that right and so
even though now science is trying to say
and I believe it is a financial thing
well this is only really affecting the
younger population
um we're seeing so many articles coming
out you know in in the medical journals
that are saying this isn't just the
young Youth and adult people that are
immature but people period are being
affected by this false reality this
false family exposure yeah if you could
choose
at what age a person could get on social
media or what would be appropriate what
age would that be while it's a really
hard one I don't know somebody's going
to get me for this
so the question you're asking me if I'm
understanding correctly based on how
your brain is wired and how it's made is
there a age that your brain is safe to
ingest social media yeah and so that's
very controversial right because no
matter what age you are the way social
media is actually crafted it's not
really made to support your brain health
does that make sense at any age yeah and
so really the answer would be I don't I
can't recommend an age that would be
safe when we know that this mechanism is
being created to capitalize to
capitalize on your on how you're made
does that make sense so yeah I know that
answers I had another question too like
can social media and good mental health
coexist right right actually right right
really absolutely because the thing is
there are things that you can get from
social media that support your mental
health right so think about times where
you do watch something that is inspired
operational the issue is actually man so
social media and the engagement of
social media is symptomatic I believe
you know what I'm saying like why am I
engaging this material in what frame of
mind am I engaging this material is what
I believe really sets the stage so if
I'm getting on social media because I
want to numb right I want to
disassociate I want to come out of my
reality well I'm going to be more likely
going back to the analogy of the family
to experience negative effects from it
but if I'm
um engaging in it for a more
intellectual purpose for instance you
can watch a sermon on social media right
you can watch this show on social media
right then this is going to help me it's
going to feed my brain right but at what
level am I engaging the information so
right that's a principle I think I would
look at when I'm thinking about is this
healthy is this not healthy right
because I think one thing for me that's
so overwhelming is just how much
information can come to you within the
span of an hour so it's like sure I
could be watching One video but then
like my brain is still saying all the
suggestions on the side and then on
Instagram you have like all these you
know three to 15 second reels that are
just you know when you look at those
hours and hours and hours it gets so
overwhelming for me and so even if I do
have
um all this positive information that I
could collect it just ends up
overwhelming overwhelming me and so
that's that's powerful that you're
bringing that out because
um researchers have ever actually looked
at Tick Tock and saw that they don't
have a hard stop you know there's
there's not a hard stop when you're
doing social media usually if you're
gonna watch something like YouTube you
have to opt in right you know just
opt-in opt into it whereas with Tick
Tock specifically you're just in the
from the moment you and engage that app
you're just in it and there's no hard
stop put in Tick Tock to so that you can
be able to opt out really and so now
people find that wow I didn't mean to be
on here all this time but I have because
there's no because based on how they've
studied our brains and see how that
works that there's no hard stop put in
there to help you disengage from the
material and you know if you want to
I've noticed that my hard stop when I'm
if I'm scrolling on Tick Tock and I have
nothing else to do I'm scrolling and
also I'm like I don't want to see that
guy trip over that thing anymore scroll
past it oh I don't want to see that that
happen anymore and after about five
videos I mean disconnecting
disconnecting I'm like I don't have to
do this whoa I'm getting such a negative
reaction from this thing right here why
do I have to keep scrolling and that's
when I turn it off that's when it
disconnects yeah but
but you're right there is no stop button
there's no
um there's no hey this video is finished
now like on YouTube yep and that's
important because you brought that up as
well candy the idea that this is on
purpose you know the longer you're on
here the more this company this
Association whatever is going to benefit
from you being on there and it's not
about your brain health and wellness
it's it's about how much money can I
make from you continuing in this yeah I
think it takes intentionality and also
taking like some responsibility as well
when it comes to because we all know
what's going on when you open the app
you know how Tick Tock Works how any
social media platform works there are
actually apps you can download or I
think it might be in the settings of
iPhones where you can actually put a
timer and the app shuts down after a
certain amount of time that you've set
so just doing little things like that
can help us as to combat how the apps
are designed man that's really powerful
I'm glad that you brought that in
because it really makes me think about
you know don't some people are like well
man you know how how can I stop this how
do I break free you know like
I enjoy this I feel like in my life
there's nothing enjoyable you know what
I'm saying just talking about that
psychological aspect of it you know if
you take this away from you what will I
have you know and so sometimes in shows
like this I don't want to hear it I
don't want to hear the truth you know I
don't want to I don't want to know but I
love how you brought that up like there
are things that we can do to kind of
guard our minds and to kind of help us
to be able to break free and you talked
about it like being able to shut down
the app being able to take off
notifications right that you're not
being notified every time something's
being downloaded one of my favorite
mentors said the best information is
that which you actually seek after not
that which just comes to you if that
makes sense and so I really love that
idea and I just want to say to those who
are you know battling
um
this is not just about Tick Tock you
know it's not just about
social media I love to think about
getting to the root of matters does that
make sense like what what's in my soil
when I'm thinking about my own
depression and anxiety my own feelings
of disconnection what's actually causing
it you know what I'm saying and so it's
um it's important to
see why am I connecting to this material
and what's a better connection that's
actually going to feed the root of why I
might just be losing myself on Tick Tock
um another thing I wanted to say when we
talk about how to break free from it is
actually the idea of removing the
trigger you know and there's many ways
that this can happen I mean some people
actually decide you know what I'm gonna
not have the app
um some people decide you know what
that's not even good enough I'm gonna
like actually downgrade my phone you
know and I'm gonna actually not use a
smartphone because I know myself I have
addictive Tendencies You know I have
Tendencies towards you know going
overboard and so
I'm going to do that you know and
somebody might think that it's extreme I
think was even more extreme is not
actually living your life and missing
out on responsibilities you know you
can't pay your bills or you fail a test
you know because this thing is consuming
you okay for some people this might
sound extreme especially for the the
broader population who don't let it get
out get let social media get out of hand
to the point of like they're not showing
up for work or they're failing in school
some might actually argue that there is
a connection between social media and
their social life like without social
media they don't have a social life is
that a myth or is that an actual reality
that this is kind of needed for people
to be sociable right so with me um as a
coach I like to ask questions to
questions sometimes when when things
like that because I really believe each
person has to figure out for themselves
like the scripture says you know
um be persuaded in your own heart right
and so my question to a person that says
well I don't let it get out of hand I I
want to ask the question well are you
sure because a lot of times we're
thinking that something's not a problem
but we don't realize that it actually is
you know so it's like ask your friends
you know how present are you really so
people will say oh I'm using social
media because this is my socialization
and yet here we are all together but
you're here you know what I'm saying
yeah and you see it when you go to the
restaurant where there's a whole family
sitting together and everyone's on their
phone so where's the um did you go to
the restaurant to be on your phone or
did you go to the restaurant to eat with
your family you know
um so those are the questions that I
would put forth
um to that question you know is it
healthy you know am I it's not that bad
you know I remember when I was addicted
to food right and I didn't think it was
that bad because hey I'm not shooting
any body I didn't steal I didn't steal
the food you know what I'm saying
um and yet I couldn't stop you know what
I'm saying I would want to stop I would
say to myself I've had enough and yet I
had to keep going and that's like there
were Roots there there were there were
reasons and I noticed also that
depending on how my day had went
depending on who I interacted with that
this issue came up for me so like some
people they don't think exactly they're
triggered some people think oh you know
social media isn't an issue for me but
now when I'm triggered and all of a
sudden I've spent the rest of my day and
so social media yeah you know something
my wife and I practice is um we've been
doing this a few times not all the time
but when we go into church we usually
leave our phones in the car and uh it's
it's been a blessing because we don't I
mean now everyone's going to go look for
my phone in my car right hey don't steal
my phone what kind of car do you drive
yeah
but um we do that also sometimes not all
the time but when we go out to eat
together yes we leave our phones away
that way we can't just like because it's
it we don't even think about it right
you pull on your phone you go let me
check that I just got a ding and now you
spent the last 10 minutes while your
partner's over there are sitting there
by themselves and we both said to us hey
you want to join join me over here so
absolutely I mean and it's definitely
happened to me as well even though I
study this I talk about this I train
this I too have to catch myself you know
sometimes I'm as a media content creator
you know
um I'm I'm there to leave some content
that is of use and then next thing I
know my sister's like I mean not my
sisters but my daughters are like hey
Mommy were you still gonna play with
this I'm like yeah I'm coming look here
we go I'm coming I'll be there in a
minute and a minute like what 20 you
know what I'm saying yeah and so um I
what one thing that has been really
helpful for me is that because I know
that I'll I will be using content to be
a blessing is actually putting that
timer on I think you talked about that
you know and saying okay the timer is
off this is my opportunity to give me
that hard stop that may not be there on
Facebook or on Tick Tock you know it's
that hard stuff to kind of wake up my
brain and say hey
um something else is supposed to be
happening right now and you know you can
obviously ignore your alarm but at least
something was put in place yeah yeah
disrupted your mind yeah you know
finding the the root is important but
identifying it doesn't necessarily take
away the draw that's right right that's
true and we did make mention of like
there's apps to cut off the time and all
of that but yeah someone could just go
back into it and it just brings up the
principle that once you've created a
definite deficit you have to fill it
with something so do you have any tips
on what someone can do and I hope it's
just not like go for a walk because you
know how you can't necessarily walk for
five hours when you were like uh
scrolling for five hours so what
practical steps can someone take to
transition off of their screens to life
so somebody's actually not gonna like my
answer when I do say go for a walk
what I'm actually going to say go for a
walk and here's why so let's let's give
a few more things though why why why go
for a walk or why so first the first
thing I want to say in answering that
question is
honestly truly like the roots really
matter you know why am I doing a
particular Behavior because you find
that when you're able to settle some of
the issues in your life or settle some
of the things that are causing you
anxiety you just will intrinsically
automatically make different choices you
know and so you know being a mental
health coach you know just a little plug
I I love when people come and we are
able to settle some of those matters
that have been unsettled for them so
that now they just automatically stop
overeating you know what I'm saying it's
not even a matter of okay I've got to do
these 12 steps sometimes you know it's
like man this this got settled for me in
my mind this issue of why this happened
or that happened and now I find that
some of the behaviors that I just
couldn't stop doing I don't do anymore
and so that's one getting to the root
right being able to settle issues in
your life knowing how to do it and I do
have a wonderful tool for us to talk
about that will help in some cases okay
and so then another thing is actually
Hobbies I mean I know that people are
like Hobbies rolls eyes right here we go
but Hobbies actually help to create a
new pattern like even learning a new
hobby where you're able to engage your
brain from a different from a different
um on a different level you know and so
imagine especially if it's a new hobby
you know so can I challenge that oh come
on because now I have a new hobby I'm
proud of my work I want to snap a photo
and put it on social media so you can
make money from that now it's always a
competition that is true that is true
that that is actually true and you know
what you get a high five okay
because I'm going to be honest that is
true it can totally lead you back into
the cycle but now think about this you
know you are still strengthening your
brain by creating that new hobby because
if you don't do the hobby you talked
about it right like feeling the the
empty vessel all I have is Tick Tock
well if I can create a platter or a
plate of different things that I can
actually do so that Tick Tock isn't my
only Outlet because it's one thing to
like hey I just you know did my hair
look at this cool style I'm going to put
on Tick Tock boom but I know I have
other outlets versus I have no other
Outlet I don't know what to do when I'm
bored I don't know what to do and I'm
triggered I didn't even realize that I'm
triggered and that's why I'm engaging in
this Behavior it's a diff it's coming to
tick tock or some of these social media
platforms now from a different place
yeah you know so what do you think about
that like no I agree yeah I I think like
for me personally because I had always
struggled with social media and um
I had to come to a point like what I was
doing before was whenever like before I
go to bed at night I would turn my phone
on airplane mode
um because for me just deleting the app
my brain is still like did I get
notifications like I sat in the back of
my mind and at some point it was just
torture right you know so then I started
deactivating my account but then like
once I felt sad or something I would
reactivate it again and so then
um what I started doing was putting my
phone on airplane mode so that in the
morning when I wake up and I check there
are no notifications my alarm still
works but there are no notifications so
then it's like it is like my first few
thoughts aren't just this huge rush of
information and I've noticed that during
those times especially when I replace
that with spending time with God I'm
less anxious I have more Focus exactly I
I can eat breakfast and I'm not rushing
you know and I'm just in a better place
compared to when I I just start my day
with social media so seeing what I hear
you saying is that you're even
practicing presence like being present
like you are in your life you know
you're not just eating while you're
looking you know at something but you're
you're taking the time to be mindful and
you know sometimes the word mindful can
sound like a dirty word depending on who
you talk to but it doesn't have to be
you know but and being mindful about
what's going on in your life did you
know it's really Insidious of some of
these um platforms they are embedding
things that are going to trigger trigger
you and make you feel like you need to
actually be on there because they know
what um that we've been Mass traumatized
by different things you know in fact
some of the trauma's been created and so
even though you may think that you're in
a safe environment safe place on Tick
Tock or some of these other places you
will find that every now and then and
and go with me on this you'll remember
oh this child was abducted oh this
horrible sad thing you're like wait
where did this come from like I this why
is this in my feet they just came in
there you know and so uh oh scarcity a
scarcity there's you know food shortage
and you know different things like that
it has nothing to do with what you've
been looking at and I dare you when
you're well okay no I don't dare you
scratch that look out for it you know
look out for it you know should you find
yourself on social media watch how it
just kind of Pops in there the the bad
or boring videos and also triggering
things that can cause responses
emotional responses in you yeah yeah can
we go back just just for a second go
back to presence and mindfulness because
they were two key trigger words in the
New Age movement so I want to understand
what you mean by that oh that's good
that's good thank you for that okay so I
I love that you asked that because
you're right those are words that make
people kind of like what are we saying
you know like so should I do yoga right
so when I'm talking about mindfulness
the concept actually came from the Bible
you know Jesus said take no thought for
tomorrow for tomorrow take that for
itself sufficient of the day is the evil
thereof and embedded in that scripture
is the principle of being present right
the principle of like not jumping to the
Future
um to try to figure out what's going to
happen because a lot of times people who
suffer with anxiety that's where their
thoughts are right like what's going to
happen if I fall what's going to happen
on this video if I don't do the right
thing I was having that same you know
situation you know what I mean so we're
we're in the future which is causing us
anxiety or either we're in the past
where there's nothing we can do about
what's already happened instead of being
in the present where we are mindful I'm
mindful of the fact that I'm here with
you all and that we're having a
conversation and I'm not allowing my
brain to jump to another time that's not
right now where I can start to have
anxiety you know that's really the true
basis of mindfulness when it's not being
you know perverted by what other people
some people may try to make it mean but
it's really really just this idea of
being right here in the moment and being
connected to what's going on yeah that's
good I want to make sure that you got
through your list because we kind of
derailed you started off saying yeah go
for a walk right um or pick up a hobby
was there anything else that was that
you could suggest well I really wanted
to talk about why you know so when we
think about like okay we talked about
going for a walk and somebody be like oh
not going for a walk right but the
beautiful thing about going for a walk
is how it's going to engage your senses
you know God has made so many beautiful
things in nature that actually
um ground us which grounding is another
word that people use in New Age to be
like oh that's you know
to make it something that it isn't you
know when we think about grounding our
bodies have been fearfully and
wonderfully made you know and so they
are made to cause us to go into fight or
flight because we need to or to calm us
down but sometimes because we have lost
the art of being present and being in
tune with our bodies actually being able
to get out into nature and smell the
fresh air Feel the Sunshine on our face
create those beautiful memories for our
amygdala to tag and say hey that was
good that was wonderful right
um and then create a pleasurable
experience from something that is
natural right
um instead of something that is
unnatural and so um also grounding there
are two different types of grounding and
when we're looking at this we're looking
at sensory grounding right and when we
talk about sensory we're talking about
our touch right and so what we feel like
we talked about we're out in nature and
we're taking that walk right so we feel
we feel the breeze you know we see the
mountains these sea sea centuries see
the mountains and it's really calming
and peaceful it reminds us that you know
while the mountains are higher than me
something else is higher than me sensory
grounding that's so powerful but now we
can also talk about cognitive grounding
which um
that is also a Biblical principle that
has been um unfortunately maligned right
because Jesus would tell I mean not
Jesus but um in the Old Testament God
talked about you know
um keep my word ever before you it's on
the tablets of your heart you know keep
it in your mind posted places where you
can see it right because it was supposed
to remind God's people of who and how he
was and so when we talk about cognitive
grounding we can use our frontal lobe
our minds to remind us of who and how
God is and who we are in him by using
things as simple as scripture you know
or you know even affirmations has become
a bad word in some Christian circles but
affirmation is really just us reminding
ourselves who we belong to that we we're
God's children you know God you told me
that um you you know the end from the
beginning you you said that you would um
I'm precious in your sight you know that
you would perfect that which concern to
me all of those things can really help
us to ground cognitively you know and so
um these are things that we can actually
do to break free and the reason it's
breaking us free is because it's helping
us to deal with some of those internal
issues that subconsciously we might not
even be aware of but in getting out in
nature and doing those Hobbies we're
healing The Roots yeah so what I hear
you saying is we should be doing what we
were created to be doing oh that's good
instead of necessarily what man has
created around us I even see us when
we're in the I I've often thought when
we're in the middle of the city at night
you look up and you can't see these
Stars you can't see that thing that's
above you or that that's that and you
can't say wow who else is out there and
who made all these things but when you
get out of the city you're out of man's
creation and that's that's the parallel
I'm going for and you actually see all
this stuff and you you say man I not
only can feel the breeze I can see the
tree trees I can see the grass I can see
the stars there's something bigger than
me there's something amazing going on
here yes and I love how God has made it
like we can actually discipline our
minds that no matter where we are we can
we can break free even if we're in
prison you know I think about Victor
Frankel who is in the concentration
concentration camps you know he could
not you know all around him was death
and sadness and destruction and and
degradation you know but our minds were
so fearfully and wonderfully made that
in his mind he could imagine something
different and sometimes people think of
imagination even as being like Oh what
do you mean your imagination but God
gave us the ability to imagine Heaven
you know imagine what it will be like to
live in a world where there is no sin to
be in a place where things can be better
it actually physiologically does
something to you it literally creates
patterns in your brain of something
better here right it gives you that
dopamine boost exactly exactly and so
um these are all tools God has given us
and man is aware of it and so
um unfortunately
sinful men that are bent on sin use
those different capabilities that we
have and they thwart them and then Satan
will even come along and try to take
them from us and even make us feel that
oh using your imagination being able to
ground yourself that these are bad so
don't use these tools you see what I'm
saying yeah
as you're speaking I'm reminded of a
story that I heard growing up there was
a person in a hospital room and then he
was there for a while I don't know what
disease he had but then he got a
roommate as hospitals and sometimes do
have two people in a room and but this
person whatever they were
in the hospital for made them very
depressed right and so they would stay
in their bed with their head under the
sheets and they were just turned away
from the other patients so the patient
who was there first started
telling his roommate I suppose what he
was seeing outside of the window right
look today there's a marching band or
you know telling stories about you know
look there's a little child doing this
with their parent or what have you and
describing the scenes of the park and
all this type of stuff and slowly but
surely he saw the mood of the roommate
starting to change until one day he
turned over finally and looked out the
window you know it was there a brick
wall
but it completely changed his roommate
because it's like there's something more
out there to something to live for and
while that thought came to mind
a question came with it because I'm
thinking of those people who are like
gearing up to break free from this
social media addiction or maybe someone
who maybe needs to be a little bit more
sympathetic to someone who's dealing
with social media addiction is it okay
to make a comparison between social
media addiction and let's say alcoholic
addiction to where there is withdrawal
and there is a process to get healthy so
to speak is that the case within social
media and how can someone work through
that and maybe prepare for that wow
that's really good thank you for asking
that so there okay there are two ways
that we can look at it right when we
think about social media addiction
someone might argue that it's actually
not addiction they will say this is
actually behavior these are behavioral
issues and so
um they will want to treat it
differently okay so if this is a
behavior issue how can I change
behaviors which is kind of what we've
been talking about in a sense how can I
change my behaviors so that I can get a
different outcome whereas when we're
talking about addiction sometimes we
actually need to go a different route
and I am in no way an addiction
especially so I just want to outline
that but just in the work that I have
seen in um addiction and the work that
I've had to do for myself and addiction
sometimes
um you can't just go cold turkey on
something absolutely not with an
addiction in fact some people say I you
know you will hear testimonies where
people say oh I just stopped drinking
and I was fine but a lot of times and
people have had that situation but a lot
of times
um you can actually become sicker it
could actually become a life and death
situation for you to just cold turkey
and addiction and so um there are some
people who say that social media is an
addiction and some people say it's a
behavioral issue and so that's a really
tricky one
um in terms of answering your question
but I think that as Christians and as
people
empathy empathy empathy we should always
um should is actually something we're
not supposed to say but anyway
um empathy is something that helps
anyone right of empathy empathy is
something that we want to think about
when we're working with our loved one or
we know someone who is struggling how
about we put it that way we we we're not
here to diagnose we can't say whether
this is an addiction or this is a
behavior per se or their comorbidity
where they're both happening at the same
time right the idea that two things are
happening at the same time when it comes
to this sickness or issue we we can't
say that but what we can do is that we
can be a source of encouragement we can
be a source of understanding
um we can be a resource that points them
to other resources that may be able to
help them wherever they're at whether
it's Behavior or addiction or both does
that make sense and and that's really
important for people to know because if
I keep trying to I remember when when I
was battling with the food addiction I
kept trying to stop stop and you know
what happened by the end of the day I'm
like
oh I couldn't eat enough food my stomach
was ready to pop I'm like throwing up
and I'm just gorging it you get what I'm
saying because I'm trying to do it and
not realizing that I had an addiction I
had a problem there was a root that
needed to be addressed before you know
um before I could stop doing engaging at
Behavior right and so
that's the best way I could answer that
you know have empathy with the person
you know suggest to them what you're
seeing you know what are you seeing you
know I've noticed
um Mia that you are not present
um it looks like you're not really you
know getting into the things that you
used to get into the things that you
love how are you doing what what's going
on um and now like what's going on but
like you know what's wrong with me this
is what I'm noticing I'm noticing this
this and this and I'm concerned about it
could you talk do you mind to talk to me
about what I'm seeing what do you think
is going on
um and the person depending on how old
they are I you know they may shut you
down they may not want to respond but at
least you open the door which is the
most important thing like I've opened
the door I've made you aware that I see
something you know and always being
willing to revisit it yeah I guess good
yeah that reminds me of something that
um Candy Candy told me because I don't
know I don't like maybe I'm a special
case I don't know but if I let something
go that's addicting I just either what
what was underlying has always been
there but I just picked up something
else right so it's like okay I can get
on social media but then I'm gonna turn
to food and it's like oh you're gonna
take my food away okay I'm gonna go
shopping yeah and it's just like this
non-stop thing and so I had this thing
for a while which I still kind of do
with hot Cheetos
oh boy
anyway this is a loving space that's
right and I remember when
um because she would always encourage me
not to and then I still would yeah and
she's like man you're because every time
I'd say like you know I'm craving some
hot Cheetos she's like what you're
looking for is comfort and I'm like oh I
always get nervous when she tells
stories like this because I don't
remember what I say
it is it's like something with me is me
I feel like something's missing and so
I'm taking something to replace that and
it's not necessarily fulfilling it's not
what I need it's what I think I need or
what I'm I
okay like let's go here so like when
when I was little I never got
um
I didn't grow up in a emotionally secure
place right there was not really
emotions showing the home how love was
expressed was stuff right it's like oh
yeah you're crying here's a new toy
here's what it was always just right
I've never had to worry about anything
in terms of like material possessions
and so growing up it's like oh I'm
feeling sad today I would just go
shopping or I would just go buy myself
something and so that's just something
that so it's a cultivated tendency
exactly so when she said that you're
looking for Comfort no one had ever said
that to me I never knew why I did those
things but it's like calling it out it's
like something's missing and you're
distracting yourself and I feel like
candy just um on camera okay she's I
think you have like a gift you know and
I think you should explore that you know
pray about it because you know it just
seems like you have a gift for
um being in that mental health coaching
space you know whether it's coaching or
or you know you'll you'll look into it
you'll pray about it but um I just feel
like I sensed that from that sense like
you know weird like which are really
weird about those kinds of things that's
not how I mean it yeah
I know thank you just feeling your
energy
not the energy it just I'm observing let
me use vocabulary I'm observing in the
way that you talk in the way that you
think the way that you ask questions
um that's really helpful in this space
you know
um and that you come off very thoughtful
and non-judgmental and so that's what I
mean thank you you know I I you admit or
something nothing weird or anything like
that but um you know that's really
interesting that you said that because
as you were speaking about it I know
that whenever I was sad as a kid people
gave me food you know what I'm saying
and and I had to catch myself because
we're talking about patterns right and
jumping into social media can be that
pattern like oh um child I'm busy here's
a phone yeah here's a computer right
here goes the pattern because I'm busy
pairing it and I need to do this so here
you go so now a child grows up oh I miss
the connection which is a huge word if
no one takes anything else from the
video connection connection
um that is a root often that there's a
missing connection for us from from
something that we need you know and
sometimes Christians will be like yeah
you need to be connected to God you know
but God didn't just make us to be by
ourselves you know he he made us in a
community he didn't leave Adam by
himself with the animals right he gave
him Eve and then a family you know and
so we are created to be connected but
they would give me food you know
um yeah and and food would then it
became that pattern that made me feel
better when I'm sad when I'm angry there
goes food it's all it's always been my
friend and my enemy you know in a sense
and so that can be happening for people
um with social media as well there was a
point that came to mind when he was
sharing the experience of you with like
withholding right the food from yourself
and then at the end of the day
[Music]
um what came to mind was self-talk yes
like sometimes we're thinking I can't do
this right I shouldn't do that instead
of looking at the positive let me go out
and do this and do that
um and I bring this up about the Ten
Commandments all the time you know the
translation to English isn't always that
great so it's like Thou shalt not all
the time it's like no I don't engage in
this because of my love for God and all
these things like that so kind of having
a mental shift I think will help in the
process of not feeling so deprived I
love that you said that you hit it right
on the head and while you're saying that
it makes me think about how we see God
you know a lot of times in the work that
I do that's the root that I'm talking
about how we see God and how we see
ourselves will shape a lot of our
behaviors whether the behaviors turn
into addictions or whatever the case may
be because
um if I have a toxic View you you know a
toxic self-talkers toxic image of God
even though there man there was a study
that was done by Baylor University and
it's it's pretty old now but it talked
about the that America believed in four
Gods you know that they had
um the authoritarian God and then
there's the distant God the critical God
and then also I think there was there
were people that were atheists and then
there was a benevolent God you know and
it was interesting because everybody on
some level would say oh God is good you
know our people said God is good that's
his nature and yet their behaviors or
the way they responded to people or
responded to themselves showed that they
actually believed in a critical God why
because they were critical they couldn't
and nothing was ever good enough you
know
um you know you you gotta age you gotta
a plus you know um why didn't you do it
like this and so who wants to be in a
relationship with someone who's Ultra
critical nothing's ever good enough if I
see God that way but he's also good now
I I um I don't do that well on a test or
I feel like I gotta Mark at work here
comes those Cheetos or the cake Mia you
know
um you name it you know Mike I'm gonna
do something to I don't realize I was
triggered if that makes sense yeah and I
think family plays a role into that too
so when we're used to
um because I grew up in a critical
household as well so if that's what
you're used to yes then you
automatically assume God is like that
like I punished myself a lot the whole
concept of Grace yes and God not wanting
to punish me of course there are
consequences for sin but that was
something that I'm still learning till
this day because it's just not nap it
doesn't feel natural to me like for me
it's like you did something wrong you're
gonna sit in shame for like the next six
days and you know and that's just how it
was and even the whole concept of coming
to God when you sin you know like I
would always isolate I'm like he doesn't
want to talk to me he's mad at me he's
rolling his eyes he's like why can't you
just get it together you know just being
able to know that you have that kind of
trust and that someone cares about you
enough to say like just forget what you
did just come like you know let's talk
it out man that is so powerful that you
said that because think about it like
when we think about God and Punishment
right A lot of times as kids when we did
something wrong where we saw as we're
being punished for the wrong that we did
versus what if there's the idea of
corrective measures this this mindset
that
um if I have done something wrong I'm
actually being trained on how to do it
properly
um and the methodology that is um used
to help me be trained to do it properly
might look different the the spirit in
which the correction comes will be
different as well right and so I would
even punish myself with the food so it's
like the food was
um something that was there to make me
feel better but then it's like I know I
shouldn't be doing this now I have to
punish myself the same thing like I'm
punishing myself with the food and
sometimes we even do that as Christians
like oh man I'm punishing myself with
the faith you know like because I think
that's how God sees it that's how he
feels about it you know he's castigating
me for what I've done and now I've gotta
you know fast and I've gotta you know
memorize these scriptures and go really
hard into these Bible studies but the
principle or the spirit in which I'm
doing it is not from a healing place
it's from a damaged place and so that's
really important there's so much we
could talk about but I I really want to
share this with you all it's a really
wonderful tool that I gained and I want
to just give a plug it was at the
Wildwood Lifestyle Center after leaving
the behavioral health hospital that I
gained this tool and I want to share
with you
um I've called I've renamed it the brain
detox because when you think about the
idea that you have let me just say a
bowel movement that needs to come out
you know
um if you don't get the bowel movement
out you're going to have gas pain know
and your gas is going to affect other
people like who is that you know like
all of that's going to happen and it
happens on a minute for your mental
health you know like when your brain
needs to detox what are you doing you
are short with people you're angry you
know your patients you may have less you
you may check out right and do the
social media thing from a place of you
know whatever's going on and so this
detox is really awesome and it's just it
starts off with saying today I feel and
you get to write down whatever you want
you don't have to
um make it make sense you can feel good
you can feel bad you can feel attractive
and really ugly all at the same time it
doesn't matter but the idea is that
whatever toxicity is in there needs to
come out the idea of bringing it down to
size scripture tells us to take every
thought captive right and this is
important you can't take something
captive That You Don't See and this is
why we're writing it down we're
acknowledging that it's there so then we
look at ants our automatic negative
thoughts right what are you thinking
about that's actually negative for
instance the idea oh I'll never lose
weight you know I'm always no one likes
me I'll I'll I don't have any friends
you know whatever automatic thoughts are
coming to your mind and you may think to
yourself oh this isn't helpful I need to
just claim a scripture but this will
actually help you recognize those
patterns that you have because once
again if you don't know it's there then
you're doing it automatically and you
don't realize it and you're in a sense
farting on people and you don't realize
it because you don't realize there are
toxic patterns in your mind and that's
what this is helping you to realize so
then after you do that you have a
conversation with Jesus and with the
conversation with Jesus you know I
remember doing this and I didn't really
feel like I didn't feel like I believed
in Jesus anymore and so I just wrote
down you know
like this is how I'm feeling you know I
really feel forsaken I feel like no one
understands me no one cares and I really
want this to change but for those of us
who aren't in that space and you're like
you know you're having a conversation
with Jesus you can literally say the
same thing God you know I don't
understand this you know I really want
this to change whatever it is but
remember a conversation God talks back
to us and so
be present you know allow
um God to speak to you through his word
he may bring a scripture to your mind or
later after your detox somebody calls
you and says oh my goodness I need to
tell you this story and it's just what
you needed you'll be surprised and then
lastly
always ending with praise what are five
things that you can be thankful for you
know even if if it's very simple and I
found whenever I do the brain detox I
usually have more than five things that
I can be thankful for also
scientifically Studies have shown us
that when we write it's a way of telling
our brains that I'm doing something
about what's bothering me I'm getting to
the root and this is on a subconscious
level I'm writing but subconsciously my
brain is learning that hey I'm doing
something about what's bothering me and
this can even be done with art you know
for those of you who love to draw color
paint all of that you can even do
something like this with art so wow
thank you Mia this was incredible so
much information okay you know there's
this quote that I saw on Instagram
funnily funnily enough
it said
um comparison kills Joy right good and
then there's also a song by one of my
favorite artists called Jonathan
McReynolds and it's called comparison
kills
so one of the lyrics says talking about
God he feels what you feel so ask God to
heal what comparison kills and that's so
profound because it's just a reminder
that there is no need for us to do this
alone yeah God Is With Us each and every
step of the way there is no issue too
big or too small if you're struggling
with social media or you would like to
address your social media consumption
that falls in the range of God being
able to help you with so um
I hope that you were blessed by this
conversation that we had today and that
you were able to take something away to
apply in your life we're here to support
you we're here you can reach out to us
at littlestudios.tv contact Dash us or
you can leave a comment right there
below but if you'd like to contact Mia
yes yes how can people get in contact
with you absolutely so you can
definitely reach us by going to
painunwaisted.org we'd love to hear from
you if you are watching this show and
you are feeling suicidal though we need
you to reach out to 988 okay 988 you can
text that number or you can also call
that number and it won't be a situation
where they're taking you off to the
hospital okay they know how to get you
from a hot moment to a cool moment so
feel free to utilize that service they
can also point you in the direction of
other services and so yeah so helpful
all right well thank you so much for
joining us for this episode of LED live
if you're interested in more little less
studious content please subscribe to
this Channel and we'll see you guys next
week Friday at 12 on LED live bye-bye
[Music]
foreign
to show kindness to the world
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
[Music]